our subject for this afternoon is
it's all or nothing it is all or nothing when the
angel appeared to joseph in well actually to mary
in luke chapter one and also to joseph
in talking about the son they would have
the angel said and she shall bring forth a
son matthew 1 21 and thou shalt call his name
jesus and then the angel gave the reason for he
shall what save his people from what from their
sin this was the mission of jesus christ to save
his people from their sin now the question becomes
who is or who were or who was his people well
we're told in hebrews chapter 2 reading verse 14
for as much then as the children are partakers of
flesh and blood he also himself likewise took part
of the same that through death he might destroy
him that had the power of death that is the devil
and deliver them who through fear of death were
all their lifetimes subject to bondage that is a
description of every human being so his people yes
in a certain sense the jews because he was a jew
in a larger sense all earthlings because
john 3 16 tells us for god so loved the world
and so the mission of jesus christ was to save his
people from their sins clearly if god is sending
someone to save someone else god must have
determined that the person needed to be saved
now some of us don't realize we need to be saved
but god has realized he has determined he has seen
that we need to be saved so urgently
that he sent his son equal with himself
because what we are to be saved from is
so horrible horrific and powerful in its
hold on us that not even the most powerful
angel could deliver us from that bondage
and so god sent jesus to save us and i'm stressing
this from our sins not save us in our sins
as some people would prefer
to think he came to save us
from our sins now sometimes to say what a
thing is it's good to say what it is not
so that in that sense let me say
what jesus did not come to do
jesus came to a world to a land to a country where
slavery was rampant and widespread the romans just
had slaves it was part of the culture jesus came
found slavery lived in a society of slaves went
back to heaven and left slavery because jesus
did not come to abolish the social system of
slavery and the word social is a critical word in
my statement he came to abolish the slavery of sin
because jesus understood that social slavery is
the result of slavery of the mind or shall i say
sin is the cause of slavery jesus came he
found poverty he experienced it in his own
life he went back to heaven and he left
poverty because jesus christ did not come
to eliminate social and economic poverty
he came to deliver us from sin because
jesus knew and he knows and wants us to know
that poverty is the result of sinful hearts
jesus came and found the jews dominated by
the roman empire he found the romans he left
the romans dominating the jewish nation because
jesus christ did not come to overthrow the romans
because christ understood the reason why
one nation dominates another nation is sin
let me stress again and she
shall bring forth the son
and thou shalt call his name jesus for
he shall save his people from their sin
now what is sin let's go to the bible's
definition of sin first john chapter 3 verse 4.
first john chapter 3 verse 4 as
we continue it is all or nothing
first john chapter 3 verse 4 says whosoever
committeth sin transgresseth also the law
for sin is what the transgression of the
law or sin is lawlessness or sin is anomia
sin hermitia is anomere lawlessness or without
law follow me closely sin is an act committed
against the law or a condition of lawlessness you
know americans like to say in the 1880s the west
was characterized by lawlessness so every boy with
a cowboy shooting people back and forth there was
lawlessness out in the west well there was no
more lawlessness in the west than in the east
and there was no more lawlessness
then than there is now
because there was sin then and there is now
sin is transgression of the law without law
now let's look at verse five also first john
chapter three as we continue it's all or nothing
and you know that he was manifested
to do what take away our sins
and in him is no sin now let us connect
first john chapter 3 verse 4 with verse 5
verse 4 says whosoever committeth
sin on one side we have sin
transgressive also the law for sin
is the transgression of the law
the bible says if there were no law there would
be no sin now here comes jesus in verse five
and we know that he was manifested
to do what take away pause
don't say take away what yet
verse 4 gives us two things
sin and what the law see that in verse 4 now verse
5 tells us what jesus christ came to take away
tell me now what he did not come to take
away he did not come to take away the law
he came to take away sin and he left the law what
we don't need is sin what we need is god's law
in saving us from sin jesus leaves
the law right where it always was
many people believe that jesus took away the law
so that we can sin we can do whatever we like
there's no sin anything is fine everything
goes that's the way some christians live
i was speaking to a group this morning there was
a gentleman asking me were the disciples sinners
were they practicing sin and his
conclusion was they were practicing sin
and how come they were saved so that his
conclusion was and i hope i'm being fair to him
since jesus uh his righteousness is what saves
me my conclusion from what his remarks were was
is that uh i can do what i like because
his righteousness saves me it's not mine
i can live as i like because the
righteousness of christ saves me
and that's a deception under which a lot of people
labor now let me suggest why some people believe
christ righteousness saves me it has nothing
to do with me so i can live as i like
in john 16 reading from verse seven now we've
just seen that christ came to take away sin
first john 3 5 he did not come to take away
the law he left it but he came to take away sin
when we asked him to do it
john 16 reading from verse 7
this is jesus speaking he says nevertheless
it is expedient from you that i go away
for if i go not away for if i go away the
comforter will come unto you but if i go not away
he will not come unto you but if
i depart i will send him unto you
when he's come he will do several things
he will convince the world of and of and of
when jesus is on this earth he was a human
being he couldn't be everywhere at the same time
so he said it is to your benefit that i go away
because if i go away the comforter will come
unto you but if i don't go away he will not come
so i am going that he might come when he comes
he will convince the world or con or reprove the
world as the king james version says of sin and of
righteousness and of judgment three things which
encompasses the work of the holy spirit now of sin
because they believe not on me of righteousness
because i go unto my father and you see me no more
of judgment because the prince of this world is
judged but let's focus on the word reprove or
convict jesus says the function of the spirit
one of his functions is to convict convince
reprove us of sin what that means is the holy
spirit opens our eyes and enables us to see this
thing called sin seeing sin the holy spirit
now allows us to see that the solution to sin
is the righteousness of jesus christ
because there is a judgment day coming
when god will divide people into two groups
those under the heading of sinners those under the
heading of righteous and the work of the spirit
is to convict people us see an example of
the holy spirit at work soon after jesus left
acts chapter 2 verse 37 peter is preaching this
tremendous sermon on the day of pentecost and
in verse 37 the bible says now when they
heard this they were pricked in their heart
now the word prick there means to pierce
to pierce to cause mental anguish
it is only this kind of pricking that drives
a person to jesus christ because when they
were pricked they said to peter unto the rest of
the apostles men and brethren what shall we do
their hearts were touched they were troubled they
were restless they were convicted they were prick
in their hearts many people joined churches
not because they are pricked in their hearts
but simply because someone presented an argument
against which they had no logical response
so they lost an argument and because
they were decent people they came
some people keep the sabbath because
they can't find a text for sunday
not because they have been pricked in their
hearts but the holy spirit has to preach let
me give you an example of a man who was pricked
in his heart i was doing a crusade in uganda in
2001 a little town south west called massaca and
very early in the crusade effort this fellow came
i was preaching when i was finished the
deacons and the ladies came to me to say
there's a man who wants to talk to you and
he really wants to talk to you i said fine
so i went to a little area in the back of
the tent set aside for one-on-one talking
and this young man nice handsome fellow
young fellow maybe late 20s early 30s
he said pastor i i am troubled i said what's
the problem he said i just got out of prison
i was going somewhere and i saw
the handbill for the crusade
so i turned around and i came he said i heard
the message i am troubled i want my life
changed that's what he said i said he said pray
for me he said i said i'll pray for you tonight
i want you to come back to the crusade
every night he came every night
and he got baptized before i left he had told me
one of his crimes he had stolen someone's bicycle
now in a bicycle in that town very important
means of transportation and also carrying goods i
have always been amazed at the way the
ugandan men can load a bicycle with goods
so completely sometimes you cannot even see
the bicycle it's a very important means of
transportation you give that same bicycle
as american man and tell him lord he's lost
a year later i went back to the same town to
visit the church members and he came to see me
now here told me when he confessed to theft
with a bicycle he said i want to find that man
and give it back make restitution a year later
when i went to visit he saw me he said
he said pastor he said i found the man
and i made it up and i feel how
free he was troubled until he found that man
now that's a man whose heart was what prayed
and what did he do about his sin he did something
about it by whose power the power of jesus christ
he made that thing right now it's behind him he
said i'm free many of us choose not to make things
right because we have not been pricked in our
hearts so we don't sense the the the the horror
of our sin we don't see what a terrible thing
it is and so we take a casual approach well if
i see her i'll tell her if i see him i'll
tell him if i have the time i'll take some
time off from work and deal with his sin it's not
a crisis in my life my heart has not been pranked
but i'm telling you my beloved
brothers and sisters when
your heart has been pricked by the needle
of conviction applied by the holy spirit
and i mean a hot needle in an exposed
nerve that's the kind of preaching i mean
you cannot sit still until you
have made wrong things right
this way first and then that way when
that is the conviction people feel
under the leading of the spirit they begin
to deal with sin they go from conviction
of sin i see what a terrible person i am what can
i do here is the righteousness of jesus christ
it is not separate from him christ doesn't stand
here and tell you my righteousness is over there
the righteousness is christ himself and through
his spirit we receive that into our lives because
now christ changes the heart changes the mind the
conviction drives us to him a conviction of sin
a conviction of how much sin
all sin you see sin is
lawlessness living without law
an act of sin is an act of lawlessness against the
law christ came to take away the sin but he left
the law so that a man or a woman converted from
a lawless life is converted to what kind of life
a lawful life a life lived in
conformity with the law that jesus left
now jesus told zacchaeus well he told his
disciples actually in luke chapter 9 verse
55 56 when they said shall we call down fire from
heaven and destroyed this village jesus said the
son of man is not is not come to destroy men's
life but to do what to save them it all zaggers
the son of man has come to seek and to save that
which was lost what was lost when adam sinned that
purity of character that oneness with the father
that state of mind that allowed him to speak face
to face with god without the interference of
sin without the static of lawlessness without
the hindrance of iniquity that was lost and
the plan of salvation is to restore that
and to restore it means to return
it to its original condition
now in adam's condition when he could talk face to
face with god how much sin was on his heart none
n-o-n-e none not one
then if christ via the plan of salvation
is restoring the image of god in us
what is his ideal for us no sin you see
genesis 1 1 says in the beginning god
created the heavens and the earth
genesis 21 1 says and i saw a new
and anew yes now in the first heaven and the
first earth what kind of man was put in it
perfect man in the new heaven and the new earth
what kind of man has to go in there perfect man
what prepares him for location in this new
heavenly earth the plan of salvation the blood
of jesus christ listen to me no one steps into
paradise carrying even carry-on luggage with sin
that has to be dealt with right here and so we
read in titus chapter 2 verses 13 and 14 looking
for that blessed hope and the glorious appearing
of the great god and our savior jesus christ
who gave himself for us that he might redeem us
from what all iniquity and purify unto himself
a peculiar people zealous of good work and purify
now when you purify something what are you doing
you're cleaning you're removing
what impurities and it is pure
when the last bit of impurity is
removed he is purifying unto himself
a peculiar people the word peculiar doesn't mean
strange and odd it means special to god zealous
of what kind of works good works let's go to first
john chapter 2 verse 7. notice we read in verse 4
of titus 2 that christ came to redeem us from all
iniquity all it's 23 minutes to one first john 2 7
but if we walk in the light as he is in the light
first john chapter 2 verse 7 i believe i said that
we have fellowship one with another and the blood
of jesus christ his son cleanseth us from all sin
what is so difficult to understand by the word
all and i'm going to take us back
to john 16 7 and 8 in a minute
let's say first john 2 let's read
verse 9. if we confess our sins
he is faithful and just to forgive us of our sins
and to cleanse us from what all unrighteousness
when a man or a woman says i
cannot overcome sin completely
that man or that woman is giving a bad testimony
about the power of jesus christ to save a person
and the last thing you or i want to do is
misrepresent the power of god the power of jesus
christ and a lot of christians are struggling with
one thing or another and have struggled for years
simply because they are not yet
convinced they have not received
into their hearts the certainty that the blood
of jesus christ cleanseth us from all sin
let's go back to first john chapter three
and we'll get to john 16 in a minute we read
in first john three let's read from verse one
behold what man of love the father has bestowed
upon us that we should be called the sons of god
therefore the world knoweth us not because it
knew him not beloved now are we the sons of
god and it does not yet appear what we shall
be but we know that when he shall appear we
shall see him as he is for we shall be we shall
we shall be like him we shall be as he is now
what that means is the way jesus
was when he left this earth
the way he will be when he comes is the way we
will be when he meets us now look at verse 3 and
every man that hath this hope in himself in him
purify himself even as he is pure now what that
verse means everyone who has this hope in jesus
that he's coming will so live we'll do everything
by the power of god to purify his life so that
when jesus comes jesus finds him as pure as he is
stay in chapter three or
first john look at verse seven
little children let no man deceive you
he that doeth righteousness is what
righteous how even as he is righteous
i'll assume your silence
means this is fantastic news
now let me make something very
clear the righteousness we're
talking about is that life
jesus lived on this earth
fighting temptation and overcoming that
life is available to us it is required of us
you read john chapter 2 first john 2
verse 29 just across the page if ye know
that he's righteous you know that
everyone that with righteousness is what
born of him now anything that's
born of a cow is a what is a cow
then if you're born of righteous jesus
what are you righteous by whose power
and whose effort come on by
whose power and whose effort
now this is not righteousness by works it is the
combination of the power of god and my concerted
effort here's what i mean by my concerted effort
i'm still going to john 16. haven't forgotten
christ has given me victory over smoking okay and
all my buddies used to smoke they meet at a place
200 yards from my house will christ physically
restrain me from going to that house to see them
no do i have to make an effort not to go to that
house if i have to go down the street to the store
can i take another route yes can i travel when
the house is closed yes that's my effort can i
have my wife go with me or my mother my sister
my cousin so i have someone to say come on come
on walk right by that house is that my effort
yes but what is how am i actually successful
the power of god applied to my effort we have
a part to play in the victory over sin and that
part becomes when it begins when we realize we
submit to the conviction of the spirit we know
the source of power the righteousness
of christ himself and we reach for it
will jesus christ come down and force you to
study the bible oh no will he make you read it
should you read it yes verily
verily i say unto you john 6 53
except you eat the flesh of the son of
man and drink his blood which is this
he have what no life in you but god will not pour
it down your throat we have to study this this is
our effort now as we study god sends the power
to give meaning to our study an effectiveness
i mean john 16 let's go back to verse 7 8-9
nevertheless it is expedient
for you that i go away
for if i go all the way the comforter
will not come unto you but if i depart
i will send him unto you and when he's come he
will convict the world of sin of righteousness and
of judgment let's focus on sin now jesus explains
of sin because what they believe not on me
disbelief in the power of jesus christ to do
what he said he came to do is the greatest sin
and so sin is generalized as the the unbelief the
refusal to believe that jesus came to save us from
our sins and so when a man tells me or a woman
well i can be saved from some sin but i still have
to commit a few sins i am expressing disbelief in
the ability of jesus christ to save me from sin
and that is sin that disbelief
itself it is a conscious act of
the mind i choose not to believe
that jesus can save me from sin
not just sins uh actions or words we speak but
he can also save me from the very condition
that causes me to lean sometimes towards
sin why that condition itself is not a sin
of which i am guilty yeah it is a horrible
thing and i hate it and it has a power and i
need to resist that power by his grace and he can
give me the power to resist the cry of the flesh
we must believe in the job description of
jesus christ and his ability to carry it
out he shall save his people from their
sins but too many of us we like our sins
because some sins are truly pleasurable
but remember moses he chose to suffer
affliction of the people of god
rather than to enjoy what the
pleasures of sin for how long a season
yes they're pleasurable but for a season let
me tell you something that season passes by
so fast you turn around you're 60 years old
what have i done with my life enjoying sin
you're 35 you never finished
college what have i done
enjoying sin drinking smoking wasting time
skiing off every mountain you can find
we enjoy sin and so we don't give
it up but when the heart is spread
we feel the need for jesus christ and when
christ comes christ comes to do a thorough job
and the thorough job means he comes
to remove all sin from our lives
because the the conviction the pricking
creates in us a hatred for sin and i mean
a venomous hatred for sin and we
desire to be a part of god's kingdom
which is a kingdom of holy law righteous law
and as the plan of salvation is to restore
god's image in us we must understand that what
god desires for us now is that we live like jesus
i don't mean wearing the long things he used to
wear that's not what i mean i mean in character
we live like jesus when jesus was crucified
what did he pray on the cross for his killers
father father you know not what they do what does
stephen say about his killers when he was being
stoned lord lay not this into their charge same
thing because the spirit of christ was in stephen
and the same way jesus could forgive stephen
could forgive many people say i can't forgive
like that yes you can if the spirit of christ is
in me i can forgive as jesus forgave and we have
an example in the life of stephen in the act of
being murdered he prayed for their forgiveness
some of us we can't forgive
people it's been 40 years
35 we've had two three six ulcers we
will not forgive we just will not forgive
but jesus christ my beloved brothers and sisters
desires that our hearts be cleansed from all
sin all that's why he came to deny it is to
deny his power all inhabitants of the new world
would have been victorious over all sin how
many of you will say lord i want the victory
over all sin could you raise your hands would
you stand up all sin let's love righteousness
that's what the father said of the son hebrews
1 9 that has love righteousness and what hated
iniquity this is the condition god wants us
in a people who are specialists in hating sin
every head bowed every eye closed father gathered
in your presence are people who genuinely want to
put sin from their lives lord i believe it it's
written on their faces father i'm asking you in
the name of jesus to send your spirit and to
prick their hearts break the hearts deep until
it hurts hits a moral nerve and causes pain and
agony that can only be relieved by confession
and repentance and the application of the sweet
bomb of the grace and the righteousness of christ
lord fill our hearts brimful and overflowing
with a desire to be just like christ
righteous even as he's righteous pure as he is
pure and correspondingly put into us a hatred
for sin that makes us froth of the mouth just
hate it because of what it did to the world unto
jesus christ now as we leave let us leave with a
consciousness that never sleeps that god's desire
for us is to go back to the perfect condition that
our first father was in that's the condition that
will equip us for a place in the new world hear
this humble prayer bring us back tomorrow night
to hear more of this message i pray and i thank
you in jesus name that all god's people say amen
amen god bless you enjoy the rest of
the afternoon i'll see you this evening